hey
sup rr7 uh just
testing if everything is working haven't
been streaming in a long time and
this is the first time i'm streaming
from here so just checking if everything
is fully operational
uh what we are doing here is uh well
we're showing uh
a very nice tournament at the grand
master even sharich arena and
evan shahrich is himself playing in here
as you can see he is
gm dalmatian that's 101 so we're going
to be checking out some of his games
and uh well uh by by definition
some of your games as well as you guys
are probably playing in this tournament
and
challenging him so i'm gonna shift it
over to this game
uh so let's just uh check it out oh and
he's playing against whole house wow
he's actually my
that's my father-in-law i wanted to join
at the beginning of the tournament but
uh i couldn't so i'm just joining in now
but yeah
what a time to join so
uh charic versus slavko martic
let's see uh or if maybe someone else
with his exact same username nope uh
it's him
so let's see how he does uh okay he's
down two pawns
uh but it's uh it's uh you know maybe
maybe it's possible
to get something out of this as it's uh
well bishops are of opposite colors but
the rooks are still on the board uh
could be
interesting and also uh he's very very
low on time
uh we'll see what happens but either way
i'm not very glad i missed the beginning
of the game
but you know what can you do that's uh
you know that's how how it works
hey victor from compliance hey man
is youtube delay less now i i really
don't know
okay so let's just uh continue uh with
this game and
after we finish with this one we're
gonna
check what's what
hello from an indian in france how is
france man
or is it france all right so let's see
still down two pawns and it's not
looking good for him
uh but he's holding his own against uh
well
uh a 2019 european champion also
a world youth champion world junior
champion two times creation champion
uh not uh not an easy time uh playing
against this guy
and he starts pushing his past pawn
forward
uh but i don't think okay that's now
that that's gonna hurt okay that's
very nasty
yeah he has to give up he has to give up
the peace
and then can he yeah that's mate all
right it was
it was a good one and uh it it
almost worked out but uh
but it didn't but good game whole house
congratulations on such a
such a good showing against uh against
steven sharich
all right let's tune into the next one
as it's already on the way
uh he's playing against tandler from
estonia so let's let's check that out
youtube is warning me that my video
resolution is
920 uh x 1200
which is not optimal yeah i know but
it's it's just how how i roll
i'm streaming on twitch too no i'm
only streaming on youtube
i i do stream on twitch sometimes uh but
i haven't like
in a few months and i rarely stream
chess there i i streamed some zelda
and some other stuff like that
yeah that's that's true serbia one that
that is how i roll yes
all right so as this is an arena and uh
berserking i believe is allowed i i
haven't checked if anyone is berserking
but we're gonna get to that
of course of course tanish this is we
give shout outs here every day
shout out to tanish
uh you joined the tournament by clicking
on the link in the description below it
should be
in the description of my live stream
fairly certain of that
and you join uh the agat's castle group
by uh just clicking join it's uh you
know free and
no one needs the no one needs to allow
you to actually join
thanks for the contribution man you are
now 1800 in blitz that is uh that is a
lot for someone who who only
recently rediscovered chess
uh did i mention why i had to move out
uh well we we bought a new house
well not a new house we never had a
house we were renting a place we bought
a house
uh last year in september and the
previous owner lived here
until some like january
and then we started uh well we had to
not redecorate but we we had to tear
everything down you know
uh make everything new the walls the the
floors the windows okay not so much the
windows but
uh a lot of stuff so it took us a while
some
five months and then after we finally
finished we
uh we uh used the remaining time uh
those were the the few days that i was
away to move everything over
so we're still kind of setting things up
and this room is not
yet fully operational uh there are still
some sound glitches i know you guys have
been mentioning it
in um in a couple of videos uh that
there's some sort of an echo some sort
of a
130 to 150 megahertz uh
frequency that's been going on here but
i i'm still unable to locate
what's uh what's the cause of this i am
removing
objects every video from room uh you
know to
try and isolate which one is causing the
issues
uh but uh i i don't know if i was uh
successful as of yet but uh i i'm trying
so you know we will get there
so uh sharich wins uh it was a it was a
pretty
a pretty good struggle uh his uh king
and pawn engine is now of course
completely winning
so let's see how he uh how he does okay
and he already lost one game
uh he lost one game two to who he lost
one game to chris
chris d 24991
uh let me just okay we're gonna check
that i don't see chris anywhere near
here
uh mikhail also playing very nice uh
and lil mark okay so let's let's
continue here uh
to check out the the games all right so
already a lot has happened
they played the opening so fast
all right there we go
let me just uh quickly go through the
moves to see what happened
check and now this okay all right so
this is a
oh no i i i miss uh i missed the
the game i'm actually showing again from
little mark but he's leading the
tournament so
uh we can check that out as well
uh what are my thoughts on the on magnus
match uh it's gonna be it's gonna be a
really wild one
it's gonna be i don't know i don't know
how how you guys uh
feel about the the world championship
matches uh
the the fabi magnus match was was great
uh
i don't know i i i didn't get the
impression that you guys
thought it was overly exciting uh but i
i guess that's just due to a lot of
draws uh you know
uh after all all the 12 classical games
ended and then they started playing
rapid games there that was like real
fireworks
and uh later on uh okay maybe
the the match against sergey also uh
was a good one but i don't know i feel
like this one was
going to be this one will be like really
really insane
but it all depends maybe jan will
completely change his playing style for
the
uh for the world chess championship
match and then we get a completely
different match so
who knows who knows what might happen
can you know about the hashtag 2992 of
course not that is
that is the a great mystery that shall
be revealed
uh at a distant point in the future
all right so what do we have here
black struggling time wise
so we'll we'll see what he come up comes
up with yeah he's going to deliver the
check
as expected and probably double up here
probably double up but we'll see
yeah he doubles up
job is doing awesome yeah i will i will
check up
on the videos i still haven't checked
out on all of the games uh between uh
fresney and
in the duboff uh and also i have to
check up on
ancho baba's games i mean you don't have
to check up on jobal's games you know
that if your baba is playing those will
be
uh premium games uh but you know we just
have to check out which one to show
not if if there is one to show
all right 10 more seconds for for a
little mark
i thought maybe he berserked but he
didn't white is just white is just
really holding his own
that's that's odd i mean it's not odd
it's just that the
the rating difference is uh is a bit
much
uh but you know rating means nothing if
the moves that follow don't
correlate
yeah i haven't i haven't streamed in a
really long time
you're trying to join but the join
button is grayed out i think that
uh i don't think that has anything to do
with
with me uh i i i i guess
what about the age of kaiser age of
kai'sa chapter 2
is about to be released uh probably
most probably next week but i i'm
planning a separate video on that uh
after uh after sunday probably i'm
probably going to do it maybe
monday or tuesday regarding the age of
kaiser
yes i i can see the uh the chat
all right so let me just quickly run
through the moves of this game since we
weren't following okay
usually does go for the sicilian and now
this uh
very nice knight outpost on g4 and now
we
we have this okay so let's see and the
immediate queen trade
all right so he's back to leading the
tournament we'll see if anyone else can
stop him
although i i don't want to jump to any
conclusions but the one game that he did
lose
uh i haven't seen his uh opponent in the
top ten
so could be could be an engine user i'm
not saying
he is because i don't know i haven't
seen uh
the username but we will check it out
after the game
ah ronaldinho is also streaming oh that
sneaky guy he he said that he will not
stream
[Music]
all right thanks thanks man ak-47
hexadecimal you want me to speak
croatian uh i don't know
yeah it's it's pretty weird language
like a recorded video nah
how how would it be a recorded video
it's uh it's
it's alive i mean the tournament is
happening
as we speak have i read harry potter
i've read only the first book i've read
i've seen all the movies and i
i don't like them but i you know mostly
watch all the movies i don't like just
so i can you know
uh know why i don't like them but i have
read only the first book and
i really liked the book i never
continued the other books
why not collaborate with chess youtubers
i don't know it's it's not really my
thing
some people do that uh not me not so
much i'm probably i mean i i don't uh
i'm not saying i'm never going to
collaborate at some point it
might you know start appealing to me but
for the moment i'm still just doing
doing my own thing
who is the greatest chess player of all
time you tell me
who who is the greatest chess player of
all time
how is my health now my health now is uh
much much better than it was
uh you know no no heart issues
whatsoever so
still recovering a little bit but should
be should be you know
if nothing goes wrong then it should be
fully operational for a very long time
hey jonathan martin thanks for the
contribution man
whatever i'm killing i'm glad you you
think so
am i starting a streaming journey no i i
i very rarely stream but
um uh coronaldinho said that
this is going to be a nice tournament
that shot will play so i decided to
stream this one
like i said some of you guys might might
face him so
uh you know so for your game to be
recorded for for all times
harsha shah thanks for the contribution
man and hello to you too
am i going to play i might play some
games after the tournament but
for for now we're just enjoying these
top tier games
and see if anyone will be able to take a
point away from even
who would i like to play me in a movie
about my life
what's this
white resigned all right so nicely done
uh who would i like to play me i don't
know
really couldn't uh couldn't uh i don't
know
maybe maybe john malkovich that that
would be that would be an honor but i
don't know if he's you know still
still in the game but you know if i had
like
if i could choose anyone it would most
likely be him
all right so there we go ah
versus mikhail mikhail yeah
is a is a really strong player played
him many times
but uh i don't know this will be this
will be a tough nut
for him to crack uh if anyone can can
score a point uh against stephen it
could be him
as it is a blitz game so let's see let's
see how he does
he has the black pieces and it's a it's
a very exciting exciting opening
uh how will how will he even deal with
this
hey mana sunil thanks for the
contribution man
and raiders dock thanks man thanks for
contributing
what do i think fischer's rating would
be 25
today and had access to current
technology uh if he was 25 today and had
access
uh i don't think he would
ha if he it doesn't really matter if he
had
access to the today's technology uh but
if he had
the will that he had in those days and i
don't think he would
uh because uh uh he he had all the will
until he realized what
chess really was and in his uh own words
it was
basically memorization but if he
continued with the same will that he did
uh you know while he was in his prime
i i believe he would be over over 3
000 maybe
maybe maybe that's a bit much uh because
other players
would not be as close so he would really
get only a few points by winning
uh but uh maybe not today maybe maybe 10
years ago when the
when the era of engines wasn't so strong
maybe then but nowadays i don't know
it's uh it's real yeah over the 3000
yeah
it sounds absurd i know uh but uh it's
hard to
to really pinpoint uh where where his
genius lied and it was i mean he he
lived for chess there there was only
only chess for him so if anyone would be
over 3 000
it'd be him like magnus got this close
to 29
so i don't know for someone
and magnus does a lot of other things i
mean magnus is uh
uh has companies he has a girlfriend he
has
uh i mean he has a life outside of chess
bobby didn't
no unfortunately i do not speak russian
fischer did however he he he taught
himself russian very
early on so he could read russian books
no the chess is not the only thing for
me i
i do many many other things chess is you
know a
very very small part well a very big
small part of my life
all right how is how is our friend
mikhail doing
mikhail is down a pawn uh but he has a
very
very uh active position he wants to play
e3
maybe do some damage there he's probably
gonna do it right away
or maybe not no okay first this then e3
and uh it's hard to say what
we will even be able to to handle this
if he can he's up upon he has two
connected past pawns
uh we'll see i always say it's better to
enjoy than to than to analyze too much
my dog is actually behind me uh you
can't see him because he's not in his
bed
he's actually right here so i don't know
if you guys can see him like
he's chilling over there
uh i just realized since my camera is
mirrored i moved in the wrong direction
so there you have it
there's the there's the little dude
say hello
yeah he's alive don't worry he's just uh
he he's just all he likes his nap
all right so mikhail was able to crack
crack the king's defenses and now we'll
see what happens
the material is equal and he
[Music]
will probably be able to get at least a
perpetual here
it's a question if he will be able to
get more
okay so now he's threatening some very
nasty stuff queen h6 is a
beautiful beautiful move okay now even
on the counter attack attacking the rook
and uh preparing to block with queen to
h3
so we'll see
very nice okay
that could be a problem for even we'll
see
he's very low on time also oh king g4 oh
that cannot end well
that cannot end well
nice nice nice nice even
checkmated by mikhail mikhail
congratulations on this uh
spectacular spectacular victory
nicely done all right we're going to
leave this tab open i
i might need this game for later
all right so good game delivering uh uh
well uh
a very crippling blow uh to to
even let's see how he how he recovers
all right so he's facing green lantern
let's see uh what was played okay again
we have the sicilian
the knight the all right
all right so he's playing playing very
very uh cool lines
to say the least who is the guy in my
shirt
oh come on everyone knows the guy in my
shirt
what was there a perpetual maybe i don't
know
hey sun will invincible sunville happy
birthday i'll be late happy birthday man
yes of course that is mr barnes i know
you only see a fraction of his head
uh but you know uh i i hope that's
enough to
realize that that is mr barnes and you
guys said i should never call him barnes
he should always be referred to as mr
barnes so that's how we
that's how we always refer to him
yeah uh he's not the one that said
attack attack attack that's kind of
attributed to adolf anderson
but uh if it should have been attributed
to anyone
should have been attributed to mr barnes
that is true
oh yeah okay i will show you guys around
the house
uh um okay i i i might make a short
video and then show it to you because i
can't really move this camera around
it's kind of attached to my computer
[Music]
how do i release videos so quickly uh
well in croatia we have amazingly
fast internet i'm only kidding that
that's
not true uh but i don't know i actually
don't think i
i release them quickly at all
i mean i just make the video i upload it
and i don't know
there are ways i could make it the the
entire process much faster
just maybe not not so much in croatia
yeah my recovery is going smoothly very
smoothly
i've uh i've been hitting the gym for
for
a month and something and now i i'm
taking a break from the gym
just you know to not get over or over
exhausted or anything
and then i'm going to continue for two
months and then we'll see how it goes
yeah gordon lolich yeah of course uh
creation internet
number one
what is 2992 that is that is the
one of the great mysteries of the
universe we we cannot just
reveal everything
do i think nepo has a chance of becoming
a world champion
well if anyone has a chance it's him
because he is the challenger to magnus
carlsen
but uh it's it's hard to say if
fabi couldn't do it and uh
karakin was uh was even leading the
match at some point and he couldn't do
it
uh it's it's hard to say it it all comes
down to how seriously they
both prepare and how motivated they will
be i'm guessing nipple
should be more motivated than magnus
because i don't know how
motivated magnus still is i imagine he
wants to be
champion for the you know for the rest
of his life i mean who wouldn't but
it's also i don't know it's it's i i
guess it's hard for
but i think it's just my mentality i
mean he's been
the strongest for for so long that i i
guess it's maybe hard to
keep motivated but uh for
i guess for people who are at the top of
their game
that's a motivation in itself i don't
know i i wouldn't know
uh but you know who who knows
we'll see that's why i i never like to
overthink anything i just
enjoy it and you know what happens uh
it's great
what do you guys think will will nipple
be able to upset him or
or will magnus just rain forever
am i reading youtube comments of course
that's
that's what the comment section is for i
have one screen here
that's the one for showing games and
also the other one where i read the chat
i don't always read the chat yeah but i
i do
in most most videos
yeah okay i see you know people mostly
figure
magnus all day will be raining but uh
some people some people do think nepo
has uh has a chance
all right so green lantern a few more
seconds on the clock
we'll see if he can survive uh
yeah i don't think black has anything to
worry about it's equal material but 14
seconds on the clock i don't think he
can hold this
he just uh has to be careful not to
blundermate
oh g5 oh okay
g5 nice he blunders a pawn or
or does he does he go back with the rook
yeah he does
okay he's going for it now rook blocks
and then we just push the pawn to
victory
what is this wow they are they are so
fast this is insane
and it's interesting because uh green
lantern
offered the draw yeah now he
kind of yeah he got it he won the queen
that's it uh
but yeah even got his dessert victory uh
green lantern was almost there
what what a draw why a draw
what was this
was this a threefold repetition wow
that's
if it was that's pretty crazy
if it was that's pretty crazy i don't
know or or did he
just offer the draw and maybe even
accepted it
uh without actually realizing it
i don't know something weird just
happened here
who is the weakest world champion
compared to their era
oh even ran out of time oh that's why it
was a draw and his opponent only had a
king
wow oh i didn't i didn't realize
damn who was the
the weakest world champion compared to
their era
i don't know if i don't know if it's
possible to to answer that question that
would be
yeah tall as a guest no i mean above my
head yeah no that's a guest camera when
when a guest appears then tall goes away
uh but
i haven't had any any guests as of late
no yeah i i know everyone will say max
survey
because you know he was just like you
know hello i'm here and then he went
away but
uh i i don't think if we can just say it
like that
i don't think uh yeah it works like that
yeah well
i mean you can choose any world champion
but
to really claim that he was weakest
compared to the others
you know relative to the era they lived
in
i don't know that's way way beyond my
pay grade
but i would i would enjoy uh someone
you know talking about that with with
some sense
how will i continue with the morphe saga
same way as i always do
when we take a break from what's
currently happening in the world then we
go back to the morphe saga
what will uh happen next in the morphe
saga
i'm you know not at liberty to reveal uh
for that we will we will have to see
when the morphe saga continues but you
know should be
should be pretty crazy how was my lunch
it was it was pretty great
i always enjoy my lunch every lunch
no this is not the 4k cam the 4k cam is
currently turned off i'm not using it
um i'm only going to use it for some
for some videos and well very rarely for
live streams i imagine
when am i resuming my interviews with
chess players i i don't know whenever
when i manage the time
still have a lot to do with you know
completing the the moving in and
everything and
we do have the baby on the way there
there's that yeah
so we'll see
do i follow football no no i don't
hey kurt lyle very very happy to hear
that
yeah it's uh i don't know if it's weird
but when someone
says uh you know people send me emails
and messages that i've rekindled that
their love for chess
and i don't it just uh it's just the
the greatest thing you can hear that you
know someone wasn't playing chess and
then you came along and you told them
you should play chess chess is great
and then they started playing chess so
that's really really awesome
my favorite player currently uh
well uh of all times of course that's
mikhail tal
and there's no no arguing that but uh
from modern players uh duboff definitely
uh nippon she uh uh i mean
uh he's like uh like a super saiyan
duboff
okay he's a bit more correct in his
moves than dubo but uh
still he you know he plays uh pretty
crazy chess
uh and of course uh vasily vasily even
chooks still
still going strong there's uh
i don't know uh whenever someone asks me
something and then i have to
remember something i never am able to do
it on the spot
but i could be uh you know
uh i could be missing some that that i
really wouldn't want to miss uh but you
know that's
that's just how it is but yeah i i don't
think that
there's uh anyone more exciting than
duba
at the moment simply because uh that's
just for me because i like crazy stuff
and uh
his games are crazy
release your pen drive as merch
uh it's not my pen drive i actually
bought it as
merch
hey lex friedman the the the
the uh the leader of the of the greatest
podcast in the universe
uh he he probably doesn't think it's uh
it's uh true but
it is thanks man uh whenever whenever
you're up for a game
uh i will very gladly accept it and when
when you finally come to croatia we will
use
that uh that money you donated uh you
know
grab us a few beers and play a few games
and that someone finally
you know teaches me a thing or two about
uh you know about the ai in the future
the philosophy
and of course your your favorite movie
the
i always forget the name the scent of a
woman yeah
thanks lex
all right so this is the very very
interesting
uh very interesting stuff is happening
here because the matinats
lost another one black is victorious and
he lost on time this is pretty crazy
he's losing games on time
wow that is
impressive and he dropped to fifth place
something something weird is happening
yeah i don't know if lex uh officially
surpassed joe i don't know maybe not in
number of subscribers
but uh joe is not for everyone
okay i know you could argue that not
everyone is for everyone but
all right let's see
okay he's uh up against the leader and
they've just they've already played the
entire game wow
that's pretty crazy
do i like evil underage books uh i i
think i've read
one when i was in in high school but
that's it
will we ever see agatha matars immortal
yes
yes we will i have just the game
but i still haven't shown it but i will
at some point wait
wait a second yes
which cell phone do i use i use uh i use
a oneplus
i really enjoyed the i really enjoyed
the oneplus 8 and then i got the oneplus
9 plus
but i don't know uh there are there are
some things that i don't enjoy about it
uh
i don't know if you guys there's uh like
the the the unlocks
the unlock screen button is here instead
of here where it was on the oneplus 8
and then i really have to put a strain
on my finger to go all the way down
you know it's uh not not easy
yeah and it also kind of uh heats uh
heats up uh too much uh and it's still
very cold in croatia
one day i was driving uh to the capitol
and i just left it
you know on the hood and was there for
like a minute and it immediately started
overheating
yeah so uh i don't know if you guys are
are on eight or on eight plus uh maybe
you know think twice before upgrading to
nine
although other than that uh it's it's a
very nice phone
it it does charge a little bit faster i
feel
so that's you know that's the insight i
can give you
hey joel shoemaker thanks for the
contribution man
how come i had to move yeah well
we weren't living in an apartment that
was our own so we
we bought a house some eight months ago
and then we
finally moved so you know it took us a
while but but we got there
uh now we we finally for the first time
have a place of our own
and who do i have in uh championship
match that's uh something
i would rather not uh not a guess i i
i'm just gonna enjoy it
uh of course everyone has magnus it'd be
silly not to have magnus but
uh you know
uh if anyone can deliver a defeat
for magnus we'll see uh although he did
like i said he did lose the game to the
sergey
in 2016. now it was it was a very nice
one and then
uh then karakin had he had i don't know
if it was a win or an easy hold
uh but he missed it and then magnus took
his chance and equalized and then of
course magnus crushes everyone when it
comes to speed chess
uh i don't know uh someone is saying
that i should zoom out
i should zoom out of what i don't know
if
there's anything wrong with the screen
if there is uh sorry i'm
my my setup really isn't showing it
but no it's it's it's okay
am i going to dubai for the world
championship uh
i might be yeah i might be it all
depends how it how it goes with the baby
if everything will be all right with
with the baby then probably yes uh
you know but yeah i'm not planning
anything like
if i manage i'll go if i don't you know
zoom into the beard yeah
ah they just want to see that oh
ah okay
all right so tanner from estonia really
playing uh playing it well
i i again accidentally didn't choose a
game where even is playing i don't know
how that happens
how do i record my videos i uh
start open broadcasting software i click
record and i talk like this
that's that's how it is
how old is medo medo is 15
as of as of march
do i know sergeant charles yes yes i do
hey jason robertson thanks for the
contribution man very very happy
you look forward to these the creations
of mine
what sorry i was just looking at the
chat
what is this and what is the king doing
so we had this check
check check wow very nice very nice
good game green lantern good game green
lantern
all right so green lantern now leading
the tournament and the shardic
is in third place with uh uh with uh
a couple of rough games uh there's still
time there's 22 minutes so
you know if he if he can get uh uh get a
berserk
in and maybe you know uh maybe grab some
full points uh maybe
maybe oh no berserk allowed chronologino
disallowed berserking
that's what i'm missing yeah well how is
no one berserking that's i mean that's
weird
all right so sorry i
missed that one i don't know why it
keeps
there's 926 players so why
can't we get
maybe he's on pause or it's really
taking that long for him to find a
challenger
really weird hey sharp man thanks for
the contribution
no i do not speak french i once uh once
uh uh found a youtube video you know
learn
french like fundamentals and you know
for beginners and i
tried watching it and i did enjoy it uh
but you know sometimes i get
these ideas you know let's learn let's
learn a language i
the the most i've learned like was i
don't know
i i i did try some some korean i did
enjoy that
but uh never really followed up
okay this is really weird
is the game happening or oh the game's
happening
it's just that the interface isn't
showing it happening ah
okay
favorite crypto project uh i don't know
for for for the moment uh i'm really
really liking
ailerons uh but other than that i'm
not not so sure i do have i do have a
lot of them that i like but i i
you know i'm not afraid to say publicly
that i really really like elrond
and of course nano nano is nano is the
the
the number one
no meadow is not a girl meadow is not a
girl i know you guys
uh a lot of you guys thought that uh
meadow is
actually metal like with a w at the end
but
not really he's like a meadow means fear
in portuguese
yeah doge
goes without saying it's going to fuel
mars
[Music]
no i'm not among the cross who speak
italian
i i can understand a lot of it because
it's you know mostly latin based
and you know similar to some english
words but uh
of course i cannot speak it and thanks
for the contribution
mr leon's account
all right so let's see what do we have
here
mr pawn hunt really going wild he sees
that
uh shotish is struggling in his last few
games and he wants
he wants to get in on the action he
wants to he wants to draw some blood as
well
best a prodigy chess player from brazil
nowadays i don't know
uh metalcoin is something that i
kind of have planned although i still uh
haven't gotten around to it but yeah i
am planning a
coin of my own uh that that will be
used for certain things
no no i know uh yeah english is not a
latin roman language it's uh germanic
yes
but a lot of a lot of words
in english are uh based on latin so that
that's what i meant
i don't know why but they have similar
roots
i guess so a lot of words you can guess
what they mean
no i still haven't watched attack on
titan it's
uh something that i'm planning for for a
while but
there are so many of them that i still
haven't watched uh you know
anime shows but um hopefully hopefully i
will at some point
all right so let's see uh down a minute
and uh good on the attack but i think
i think even will not have any problem
holding this
or or rather winning this
zucker torch immortal against blackburn
in london 1883.
uh yeah that that is on my that is on my
radar
yes i i am making my own coin yes that
is
something something is in the works
but it it is not something uh i i i will
reveal just yet
i'm i'm always sorry about that yeah i'm
sorry about that
uh the latinos 101 the matinees 101 is
an extremely strong player who has a
positive score against magnus cross and
its creation grandmaster even sharich
and i said that i will stream
uh this tournament so you guys if you
get a chance to play him then you have
it uh
record it forever
manga georgia manga is doing uh doing
fine uh we are uh
publishing the chapter two uh probably
next week not probably we will publish
it next week
and uh chapter three should follow
shortly so we
we should uh improve on the speed uh you
know uh
quite a lot andre andre ostrovsky thanks
for the contribution man
uh you've returned to chess after 17
years that's
you know music to my ears man
what did i do before getting wicked
popular in chess
uh pretty much everything the same
everything absolutely everything
i did i did the same um
i did uh i did go out more you know
i did uh but i guess everyone did i was
it was the before
times like we say in the age of kaiser
in the before times we went out a lot
uh and i had a i had a you know nine to
five job
much like everyone else uh then when it
got uh in the way of of you know making
all the content that i needed to make i
had to quit
and that's basically it and not much to
it
no i've never had the privilege of
playing against eric rosen
and uh even if i did it would be it
would be you know
for for fun because i i don't think i'd
be much of a challenge for eric
yeah don't forget that you were a
hardcore rapper yeah
oh yeah yeah i i don't think uh
i don't think uh i will ever be able to
forget that
what was my nine to five uh oh i i
worked uh
uh in a lot of different fields so to
say
when charlie beat xqc yeah that was uh
that was a
that was a really fine moment in chess
history yeah charlie charlie's the
legend
that game i i don't know i i i mean more
people know about
charlie's immortal against xqc than they
know uh
for the for the actual immortal game by
adolf anderson
pretty sure about that
kaushik nagarai thanks for the
contribution man
got into chess after after 10 years very
very happy to hear that
very happy to hear that uh my top three
non-world champions
who are my top three non-world yeah all
the throbbing action yeah
my top three non-world champions uh
uh rashid medina definitely number one
uh
uh vaseline vancouver definitely number
two
and uh i i don't like to think about
them as number one and number two i'm
actually going with you know the one
who's still alive number one who's still
alive and number one who is no longer
alive
and maybe um
yeah okay i don't know if you count
morphy i mean uh i i
count him as as world champion even
though he's not an official feed a world
champion
uh he's definitely a world champion i
mean let's be let's be serious about
things
who would i put on number three i don't
know
something i would have to something i
would have to think about
but you know from uh from the top of my
head definitely even chook and
ninja medina
no no uh evan chuck is the grand master
but he asked the world champions
not not grand masters do i like the
danish gambit i
really liked uh liked it a few years
back
when i still played actively but now now
maybe not so much
[Music]
do i think mvl is a weak sicilian player
uh
anyone who thinks that i don't know what
have they been doing he's uh yeah okay
you guys see
he plays the ceiling against magnus and
magnus beats him that
does not uh qualify as a weak sicilian
player i mean
you play anything against magnus and he
will beat you
what was that what was that
sorry let me just quickly okay okay
15 seconds i don't think uh it's gonna
last but we'll see
your favorite opening for white or you
mean my favorite opening for white i
think
everyone in the chat knows that so i
i i don't want to say it too often
sharp i'm also the reason for your
recovery from depression
that is uh i i i think an even greater
compliment
than returning to chess after after a
decade but you know
uh i don't think i ever suffered from
depression i don't know if that's
something you can know
i mean everyone might say they didn't i
might have i don't know
uh but yeah i you know i know people who
say they have and that it's
it's the worst so very happy we're able
to recover
emmanuel alfonso welcome to the
excellent subscribers
uh thank you for joining uh the
like like i always say it's real it's uh
the most optional
and the most prestigious club ever
invented you don't gain anything by
joining you can just
uh you know uh show your badge uh you
will you will now have a badge whenever
you address someone in the chat and you
will get access to some
smileys or rather emojis as they are
called
um they i still haven't updated them
they are still the exact same ones that
i used when i created this
but we will improve on that at some
point
i always say i will get to that when i
start streaming a bit more
but i never stop start streaming a bit
more but i probably will
yeah uh you know more and more
tournaments will happen
there are so many live events there are
bullet games there are
blitz games without increment and you
will uh
well it's impossible to make video
videos on all of them so sometimes it's
it's nice just to stream
all right let me just see if even is
playing or not
or why the interface is not
giving me the game but it's not for some
reason
okay let me just let me just refresh
this this is uh leeches is doing
something weird here
yeah because whenever you hovered over
yeah you should get a game like this
yeah okay
how old is meadow meadow is 15 you
remember that well
uh when you think he's lazy or you know
he's just doing nothing
he's actually a very old dude yeah i do
have a twitch channel as well
stephan maidan when will i get my
masters
uh title well i i don't think it's gonna
be soon since
uh i have to i have to get back to
playing actual classical chess which
currently is not
happening at least not anywhere near me
and i really haven't played in a long
time any serious chess so
it'd be uh it would take me a very long
time to even get back to
you know to the level of of even being
able to get
to get ready for for such a such an
undertaking
[Music]
do i play my fans for fun uh i haven't
in a while but yeah usually
usually in ways when i say usually i
mean uh like a year ago
i did stream and play against
subscribers i i'm planning on
reinstating that at some point uh but
you know
things are still still pretty crazy so
when it uh
all you know tones down then i'm gonna
return to streaming
who is the most underrated chess player
ever
it's hard underrated is a strong word if
someone's
underrated it's because they're
underrated
you heard i was i don't know what that
word is
s thug and these is that true i don't
know
what the word is uh
okay but you you got me interested i'm
gonna google it should i even google it
is it some sort of a weird word
ah okay okay yeah
okay thanks man thanks joel for for
letting me know
someone someone tried to trick me good
one
okay so let's see what's happening here
okay it's a very nice attack uh nikola
is trying to
to repel it but we'll see
the rook is defended now the f3 pawn
might be hanging we'll see we'll see
what he finds
yeah he totally got me i mean i i
usually
will not fall for such a trick but i
fell for this one
ah sultan khan sultan khan yes
probably uh yeah not underrated but
uh the the least known
strongest player ever but yeah you could
also call that underrated yeah
sultan khan yes that is true
all right so let's see if we have
another one okay so
number one against number two damatinas
versus green lantern they've played two
games so far
and both of them ended in a draw and
someone mentioned in the comments dario
dario from serbia says whoever wins this
is the winner so we'll see we'll see
what happens
yeah rashid chucky and sultan khan yeah
the big three
i don't know if you guys can hear it but
melo is really snoring
is furusho the future of chess uh if he
isn't i don't know i don't know who is
ah you've you've seen my evans gambit
tutorial i
i'm very happy that you've you didn't
think he was lame
all right
so time pretty equal even really going
for it he has the white pieces
so could be could be very
very dangerous here
what's nepal's chance against magnus
i don't know probably
i don't i i'd say it's 50 50 and then
you know
whoever is more motivated
but now it's probably like 45 to 55 in
favor of magnus but
uh in classical i i don't know
it's it's been so long especially for
the world
championship like finding a crack in the
defenses of
you know these prepared variations for
for the world championship match that's
that's pretty crazy
yeah no nipples no pushover of course
but but
you know magnus is kind of strong
of course barnes is uh barnes is one of
everyone's
favorite
cousin camden uh happy birthday man hope
you have a good one
you're not going to say names but the
the famous one is cheating huh
yeah grand prix is uh coming to zagreb
very soon
and everyone is coming yeah i probably
will will join them
probably that's around the time my
daughter will be born so
uh like i said i i really have no idea
what uh
what kind of time uh i'll be
left with you know to to do something uh
chest wise but
if i manage i will probably come at
least one day
like at least i'm going to come and say
hello to everyone
do i have any information on amisha
osipov i
i follow him on on instagram
it's the only place i i you know hear
about any news of of young misha
uh i is he seems to be doing well
should you start a youtube channel yeah
definitely
if that's something you enjoy it all
depends on what you're
hoping to achieve okay this is
uh this is insane now the c pawn is
coming forward okay even really took
this game seriously this is a
this is the masterpiece that's it
there is no no playing this
oh he's uh he's trying to he's trying to
get a
a draw but the king has a move now the
knight will capture with check
if the rook captures uh
oh that's sneaky wow he doesn't even
want to capture with the knight he just
wants to get a queen in
okay that's that's torturing the guy
that is torturing okay nicely done
nicely done sharich wins this that is
that is a good one all right so one
minute left in the tournament and shot
she's now leading
uh but tandler is also uh uh
uh he also has a flame and he's on 56
points so if shotish loses the next one
and if tandler can get a really quick
win uh
then then i think he
he should be winning but we'll see
okay chandler is almost okay maybe even
will not be playing anymore so let's
check up on chandler
oh chandler playing against mikhail if
he can
win this one he might uh over overtake
charge but
uh there's one minute left and the the
game has three and a half more minutes
in it so i think
i think it's safe to say that
even wins this one yeah i think even
wins this one
[Music]
easily
which solid openings would i recommend
for beginners uh any
any any and any really any uh whatever
you
enjoy playing you know play that
like everything is solid if you you know
if you know how to play it
five players who will dominate in the
next five years uh well there's uh
ferugia and uh some other four players
it's it will be hard to pinpoint the
other four but firuja is
definitely the the the one that
comes to mind
okay maybe not the crab maybe not the
crab but
uh you know
will i at some point upload my own games
of course uh there's still
i still haven't uploaded the my immortal
game so
you know still getting ready for that i
don't know when i will do it maybe it's
maybe it's yeah who knows
okay now medo is dreaming
alright so i think the tournament is
over because
uh over a minute has passed but
tandler is probably gonna win this
or not what is this
okay so now he's he's planning a nasty
discovery
yeah yeah dubo vinhal uh but
they i i don't consider them to be like
okay duboff yes
but any other anyone else uh i i would
not consider them at alireza's level
in in any time format
yeah in three to four years we might
have a joint hello everyone from
from the from me and my daughter yeah
all right so a michael
wins against chandler and uh the
tournament comes to an end so
uh shotich wins the tournament with 58
points he did have a
sort of a slip in the
middle of the tournament lost to two
games in drew one so
three kind of weird games in a row but
other than that he
dominated the event uh but the green
lantern also did a spectacular job
uh yeah he has the exact same
scores uh but he has
no what ah
uh he has yeah even even has a
more a better streak or a better streak
position
i would say so that's the where the
extra point is coming from uh chandler
also very close 56 points that's super
incredible 58 57
56 super super incredible stuff
and then we have little mark filipino in
fifth place i think he joined a little
bit late because he has
way less games than uh than the other
folks so they're very sad
that he couldn't make it in the
beginning nicola 1983 mikhail 2002
tactics forever 2800 steven willie super
player
those are the top ten and this this was
a pretty big tournament over 1 000
players
uh we're gonna uh we're gonna uh
address the other ten as well shattuck
in eleventh place
crossbar in twelfth uh jean in 13
coronaldino in 14th place that's
really really amazing uh so good game
chronology i think ronaldinho was also
streaming
so that's also maybe he would do even
better without streaming but that's the
price of streaming
uh weird logic uh in 16
keep it in 17 psja 008 in 18.
uh lukail magno 2005 and 19 and
hawkhouse ho hi whole house is my
father-in-law
so congratulations on on 20th place very
very
nicely done so there you have it
uh now i i never like to discuss uh
tyler versus
medina as in if if or you know which one
i prefer better
yeah it's just not it's just not cool
those two are to be appreciated uh you
know
uh together uh so yeah uh
congratulations the
the grand master evan charich for
winning his own arena i
expected no less uh and yeah that's
that's that's it for the stream guys uh
like i said as soon as i get settled in
i'm probably gonna uh
not probably i'm gonna stream a lot more
and we're gonna you know
being joined being uh will be enjoying
some games
uh but for now i
you know barely have time to throw in a
stream here and there uh but yeah
uh we will get to that soon so thank you
all for joining in
and once again uh congratulations to
even for winning the
grand master even chatting arena see you
soon guys